bitcoin is legal tender in el salvador
and now it may be coming legal tender in
the united states what do i mean
over the end of last week we saw bitcoin
bill being pushed forward in arizona
trying to make bitcoin legal tender in
the state of arizona now back in 2017 or
so arizona made gold and silver legal
tender and so yes states can make
certain assets legal tender if it gets
approved via the legislation process but
this bill that was produced and
introduced on january 25th in arizona
would now make bitcoin legal tender
that's a big big deal not simply because
i think that some people are now going
to go and buy and sell bitcoin they
already do that in the state of arizona
but ultimately what it signals is
another milestone in the adoption of
this asset more people whether they're
politicians individuals or institutions
all realizing that bitcoin is here to
stay bitcoin is a digital currency it's
used as a store value medium of exchange
and ultimately a unit of account now
this bill was introduced by senator
wendy rogers of arizona she took office
early in 2021 it is sb 1341
and ultimately what they are trying to
do here is they are trying to not only
define legal tender but also put bitcoin
as specific legal tender the language
that it has here it says in this bill
that there is
[Music]
for the purposes of this section bitcoin
means the decentralized peer-to-peer
digital currency in which a record of
transactions is maintained on the
bitcoin blockchain and new units of
currency are generated by the
computational solution of mathematical
problems that operates indent
independently of a central bank and so
what they are trying to do is they are
trying to make bitcoin legal tender and
they're doing it by clearly defining
what bitcoin is specifically calling out
that it's independent of a central bank
and also
saying that the people of arizona
deserve to have it legally recognized as
a currency now if the bill gets enacted
it may not matter preston burns partner
at anderson kill a great quote he said
the coinage clause of the constitution
means that the power to determine what
is and isn't legal tender the united
states is the exclusive providence of
congress if enacted the bill would
largely be symbolic now of course
everyone loves symbolism everyone loves
the fact that this could happen but
could it actually have an impact on
day-to-day operations or the economy
that remains to be seen
stephen cole had a great tweet he said
bitcoin in arizona legal tender bill is
introduced intel and tsmc chip
production facilities are being built
the chamber of satoshi accelerating
local merchant adoption there's weekly
meetups in multiple cities and there's a
conference coming in phoenix in january
of 2023. now of course as i mentioned
arizona is not the only place in the
world where bitcoin is being considered
as legal tender we also saw el salvador
make it legal tender last year then
there are plenty of other bills that are
being introduced the texas governor
saying that he if he is elected the
candidate says that he will make bitcoin
legal tender in texas as well if he ends
up actually being elected now from my
perspective i think that bitcoin's gonna
end up being legal tender everywhere
every city every state and every country
may take 20 40 50 100 years nobody knows
but the fact that politicians and the
legislative system are now starting to
wake up realizing that bitcoin is good
for business and wanting to actually go
ahead and recognize it as legal tender
is an important milestone of the
adoption of this digital decentralized
currency and so shout out to arizona for
putting forward the idea of a state
making bitcoin legal tender i'm cheering
for them and i think that they're on to
something john what did you think we saw
it i don't think this really matters
it's definitely very symbolic in my mind
um legal tender i would love to see it
become legal tender everywhere right um
but i think it's really up and if it
becomes legal tender um it's gonna be
kind of as a whole nation in the united
states not just state by state we got
guys running uh their campaign platforms
i'm basically the idea that they are pro
bitcoin pro crypto and they're going to
try to make bitcoin become legal tender
like the governor of texas or the
governor governor candidate of texas so
i mean it's more and more i'm i'm very
impressed with what el salvador did last
year within six months of introducing a
bill it became legal tender and they
implemented it and rolled it out to
their citizens with their app and
everything like that um but yeah look
arizona's trying to basically make some
noise in the crypto community and kind
of get their name out there along with
cities like miami new york and texas as
well um but i don't think this really
means anything i don't think it's
actually going to become legal tender in
arizona within the next three six months
joe yeah i think it's more a case of
kind of just bitcoin is good for
business and the idea that these
politicians are going to show what they
stand for and try to gather this base uh
to push them towards election because
ultimately like look el salvador is it
was the first one to do this and and not
other countries have come forward yet
from a legal tender standpoint
and things seem to be going you know
decently well from a download standpoint
and wallet standpoint the price has
obviously fluctuated a little bit which
has uh kind of given some ammunition to
the bears but ultimately i don't think
anyone expects the united states to be
second in that race right i think el
salvador makes sense they don't have
their own currency uh they deal with a
bunch of internal problems when it comes
to underbanked and being unbanked so
ultimately that was like a good solution
for them it seemed to give people access
that may not have had access previously
it's obviously a country that's on a
completely different scale and level
from the united states when it comes to
gdp and other things but ultimately i
think what we're going to see is there
will be other countries in between el
salvador and the united states so i
don't think the united states is you
know this is uh uh going to be happening
in the near future and people are going
to be paying for things uh in bitcoin
legal tenderwise like everywhere but uh
what we should see is other countries
will adopt this first and then the
united states will probably follow and
at this point you know the united states
has more to lose than some of these
other countries do right like when you
think about el salvador uh they were in
a hard place where
this makes much more sense to them
because of their limited amount of
options versus someone like the united
states who has so much more uh kind of
put at risk so again i think that we
will uh see other other countries do it
first and then maybe united states
follows after that